why Nicki Minaj pushed back her album
release date plus a preview of the other
hottest albums come in this summer and
your boy does the American Ninja Warrior
course hey friends it is not Friday yet
but we do have the tea on some of the
biggest music releases coming this
summer and among the album's we can't
wait to get our hands and ears on is of
course Nicki Minaj's queen but the barbs
are gonna have to wait a little bit
longer than they were expecting Nicki
who had to cancel her appearance on
ellen this week because of the flu took
to instagram live to announce that she
has decided to push back the june 15
release date nick is now dropping her
highly anticipated follow-up to pink
friday on august 10th and kept it real
the whole reason for the delay asked me
it's it's them it's the better choice
so it's August 10 and I'm so excited
like the this album is just so
incredible and it's because I can't give
y'all half-assed I can't give y'all
half-assed
I just refuse to I refuse to a label
can't understand that a label can't
understand my level of perfection or me
being a perfectionist just who I am
the Queen has spoken Nicki says she
wants to put on a second single get some
dope features mixed and wants to invite
fans to the studio to listen to the
album
in the meantime Nicki has three
surprises planned that will come out
between June 11 and June 15th when the
record was originally supposed to drop
that will hopefully hold you Barbies
over one of those surprises is the album
cover and she teased the other surprises
will get your life now August 10th I
know may feel far away but you know what
there is plenty more music coming your
way and with a preview of the hottest
albums to look forward to this summer
our resident music Queen Sophia Lacey
music most wonderful now in the rap
world there are three huge albums to
look forward to a non half-assed Nicki
Minaj of course Queen is out August 10th
in case you already forgot Drake
scorpion though is coming in
soon followed by a tour with me ghosts
really excited about that but first
Kanye West is back y'all would love
everyone on June 1st plus he said he's
gonna release another collaborative
album with Kid Cudi the following week
so Connie has been busy which apparently
is why I could have make it to the Met
Gala according to Kim and now we know
why you know what we'll take the music
we're happy about it now over on the pop
front I am all about this Christina
Aguilera comeback Eileen she's got new
music she's touring with it and she's
collaborating with Demi Lovato now the
album is called liberation I love this
fresh face look really right I felt like
Bionic which was one of those last album
was a little too overdone makeup-wise
music yeah great but make up I'm down
for this stripped version Christina no
pun intended
back to basics y'all I'm loving it now
that album is due out on June 15
meanwhile ariana grande she's blowing up
the charts with her dancing new single
no tears left to cry I saw it live at
Coachella
during kygo sadness now that'll be
featured on her album sweetener which
she said is about bringing light to a
situation or to someone's life no
official date there but she's confirmed
that it will be this summer no I'm
excited for that especially gets their
first one since the Manchester bombing
yeah so I think sweetener is such an
appropriate title there too I want to
know though if she's spilling the tea on
that Mac Miller break up a new
relationship with David oh man that's a
bunny tea on line by the way if you want
that tea now earlier this week we saw
Florence from the machine on The Voice
killing it for forming their new single
hunger it's on their new album called
highes hope that will be out on June
29th and any you and I both just saw
Troye Sivan at the Rose Bowl with Taylor
Swift
hello watching him like strut his stuff
down that catwalk I love it it was such
a moment and they joined forces for the
his song my my my it was a Troy also
took the opportunity to announce that
his next album is coming August 31st
alright but now I know you gotta in on
some country so what do you got you know
me all too well after a hiatus and a few
solo projects Sugarland is back together
with their first new album since 2010
it's titled bigger and the album is out
June 8th now we've already heard some
really buzz worthy tracks off of it
including
babe written and featuring vocals from
Miss Taylor Swift the song it's about
being cheated on Denny and in typical
Taylor fashion she's not mincing words
many are wondering who's she writing
about what is the era so she said on
Instagram it was penned during the red
era so take that information do with it
what you will so if these you need to
get on the case also over in the country
world is Dierks Bentley and the mountain
now I'm super excited about this one
because I feel like I've been talking to
Turks about it forever no the album was
mostly written and recorded in the
mountains of Colorado that one's also
out June 8th and shameless plug right
now if you want to hear more about
durkas album go on and check out my show
certified country we have two episodes
on Dirk's where we talked about that by
the way the mountains of Colorado that
sounds about right Dirk's now I'm also
still holding out hope for Miranda
Lambert's Pistol Annies she's been
teasing new music from them for
literally years that's not an
exaggeration she told me years ago that
they are working on new music but now
she's been sharing a lot of
behind-the-scenes sneak peeks on
Instagram from their writing sessions so
this is awesome
yes clearly there's so much music to
expect this summer um and that's how
much east of it we have a full list of
seventeen albums you guys are that we
can't wait for this summer up at et
online.com think so take all my money
music world
alright guys before I sign off today
tonight on NBC some of your favorite
stars are teaming up for Red Nose Day
it's an annual charity event to help
raise money for children living in
poverty and kicking off the star-studded
night is celebrity ninja warrior for Red
Nose Day not only did they convince the
Stars to run the course they convinced
me to and I lived to tell the tale you
guys enjoy this take a look
no your eyes aren't deceiving you I am
on the set of American Ninja Warrior
celebs are gearing up to run the course
in honor of Red Nose Day and guess what
so my my only goal not to get my hair
wet
[Music]
this course is huge you're about to do
it I'm about to do it how are you
feeling I mean Derek Hough who I was on
Dancing the Stars with a few years ago
did it last year and I remember watching
those like this looks like so much fun
to me like it's all upper body strength
and I'm like awesome I have none of that
now we're screwed
any advice for me I mean this is the
first time I'm stepping onto the course
like I haven't even warmed up yet on the
little balls that rotate you have to go
super fast like if you stop they like
spin back and forth so you just have to
like go on bless you for thinking I was
gonna get that far I think the best
piece of advice would be to just attack
everything even if you're scared
pretend you're confident and just go for
it because the minute you hesitate
that's when things go south you know
what pretending to be confident I've
been doing that my whole life Megan oh
you got it
Oh daddy focus buddy you got this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you thank you thank you thank you
yes yes that's why I attempted I
attempted the Ninja Warrior course and
all I got was this lousy t-shirt yeah
okay but it wasn't that bad like that
was pretty good my thanks to Oprah by
the way for her guiding presents always
that's it for today we'll be live
tomorrow at 12 p.m. Pacific so coming
out with me then only refer to me as a
ninja warrior from now on thank you
thanks
[Music]